what was the most important thing in
making Steve Jobs and Elon Musk what
made them successful was it the money
they had the technology they had the
network they had or was it their mindset
what was the most important thing I
think most people would agree it's their
mindset you take away everything but you
retain their mindset they would regain
some level of their success and so if
your mindset is the most important thing
you have what mindset do you have what
mindset do you want and how are you
going to shape it most of us get a
mindset that we inherit from our parents
that we inherit from the people we hang
out with but we don't take the time to
shape our active mindset
we were talking just before I ask all of
the guests to count to five so that I
can sound check the recording to make
sure that everything's working okay and
you count it down from five am I right
in thinking that there was a period in
the past and it may still be the same
now where they missed the word five in a
countdown because five sounded too much
like fire when it was when it was
missiles so they would go seven six
four three two one fire
uh you know I I think that's a great
myth to start but uh
I think if people knew that to expect a
five after a six they'd hear a five and
not a fire
um and then probably probably waiting
for like you know launch versus fire
anyway yeah but I am a space cadet and
uh and counting down to zero uh to
ignition uh is a lot more fun than
counting up because you count up you
know it's forever you get to Infinity
eventually yeah well that's the
interesting thing when you think about
is it Bill Ackman he's that guy that
does loads of Short Selling right yes uh
the the the the reverse is if you're a
short seller you have a limited amount
of money that you can make if you're
going long then there is the sky is the
limit depending on what the company is
and the bottom is the limit too that's
also true you do have there is a limited
amount of money that you could lose okay
so you have a very eclectic history when
it comes to the things that you've done
if you know nicer way to put it sure yes
yeah uh Meandering would be another way
perhaps
um how would you describe how do you
describe your background someone says
somebody tell me tell me sort of your
story how did you get to the point that
you're at what's the elevator pitch uh
the elevator pitch both parents born in
Greece on the Island of Lesbos came here
I was born in New York expected to
become a physician I was born in the 60s
and two things happened in the 60s
number one was the Apollo program and
the Apollo program showed us what was
possible today and then there was that
scientific documentary called Star Trek
that showed us where the you know where
Humanity was going and between Apollo
and Star Trek I got the spacebug very
very hard and my parents wanted me to
become a doctor and I said yes Mom yes
Dad I'm going to be an astronaut and I
ended up pursuing both so
um went to MIT
uh really
studying molecular genetics pre-med but
on nights and weekends in the afternoons
I was doing aerospace engineering went
to Harvard for medical school promised
to complete medical school you know got
my diploma sent to my mom my dad I went
back to MIT did Aerospace and
engineering and throughout all of that I
was an entrepreneur and I realized for
me that I loved starting stuff I loved
creating companies I thought I think of
companies as the means by which you can
impact the world you know
entrepreneurship entrepreneurs are
individuals that find big juicy problems
and solve them and my first group ever
was a college non-profit called said
students exploration development of
space it grew into an international
organization I met Jeff Bezos through
that he was the president of the
Princeton chapter
and then started a space University
International Space University and then
went on to start a company called zero g
that does weightless parabolic flights
and then the first X prize for private
space flight and so I was a space cadet
for the first 20 years really pursuing
uh space I had a rocket company a
satellite company
um and that was the first 20 years of my
entrepreneurial life uh I then read a
book by Ray Kurzweil called The
Singularity is near and damn if it
didn't make a right-hand turn in my life
so Rey's a dear friend he's a mentor
he's a collaborator we've started
companies together and Ray uh wrote this
book and talked about how exponential
Technologies computation sensors
networks AI robotics 3D printing AR VR
blockchain nanotechnology how all of
these Technologies are going to
literally transform everything
and uh it really just massively turned
me on as to the Future and I made a
shift from space to really how do you
use these exponential Technologies to
take on the world's biggest problems uh
X prize went from a single prize for
private space flight to a prize uh on
solving the world's biggest problems uh
Ray and I co-founded Singularity
University that was really how do you
you know teaching entrepreneurs and
leaders how to impact billion person
problems
and that was my next you know 10 15
years and then the last decade I'm still
continuing those things I'm not as
involved in space I'll go back to space
but only when I've got a few hundred
million dollars in my pocket that I can
really invest in this because space is
not a poor man's game
um but the last decade has been uh
really focused on longevity on health
span how do you add 10 20 30 healthy
years on on your life so
very briefly I've started about
six or seven health and biotech
companies
um
uh have a a half a billion dollar
Venture fund that's involved investing
in two-thirds in biotech and Longevity
one-third in exponential Tech
um written a a number of books
and that in four minutes or less is a
very quick summary what do all of those
projects have in common
my passions
um I am driven I am a passion driven
individual I do not do anything unless
it's what wakes me up at you know 5 30
in the morning
so my passion of it's It's Grand
challenges it's like there is no problem
we cannot solve right we can open the
space Frontier the space Frontier is the
ultimate Destiny of humanity whatever we
evolve to a thousand years from now
you know we're going to look back at
this moment in time when the human race
moved off the planet irreversibly
um exponential Technologies solving
billion person problems I'm I believe
there is no problem we cannot solve
right I really fundamentally believe
that that we have the ability to uplift
every man woman and child on the planet
and that we will technology is the force
that takes whatever was scarce and makes
it abundant I'm gonna talk plenty of
examples there and then the biggest
challenge is and the biggest benefit
there is no greater benefit than giving
someone uh Decades of a healthy lifespan
all right there was a study done at
Harvard
London School of Business in Oxford that
said if you add one healthy year
to the global population it's worth 38
trillion dollars the global economy it's
massive
so that stuff is all driven by what I I
teach something called Finding Your
massive transformative purpose your MTP
and I teach this to all the CEOs I I
Mentor I I run an abundance 360 program
which is a year-round program
for uh 360
entrepreneur CEOs and about 2500 uh
entrepreneurs online anyway uh finding
your MTP that wakes you up and keeps you
going because all this stuff is hard
it's really hard and unless it's driven
by an emotional energy uh that's your
calling in life you're going to give up
before you get there there needs to be a
reason for you to put up with it being
hard it's going to be difficult things
are going to get in the way and purpose
meaning a sense of existential
connection between you and what you're
doing is a significantly better
motivator than a joker willink
motivational video or some loud rock
music or enough caffeine or just grit
and determination or whatever it is that
you end up relying on I love the idea of
using
um are you fired up when you wake up in
the morning as the proxy for are you
doing something that you care about
because
it's the easiest heuristic when you wake
up in a morning
are you excited about the day that you
have in front of you or even if the
day's gonna start even if it's
back-to-back meetings and whatever else
is it still is it still cool is it still
fun what you're doing do you feel like
you're connected to it 100
and and it's um
I think if you don't have that in your
life uh your job is to find it
right that's ultimately uh what every
person can have and I think the
technologies that are coming online
today
uh are able to help you
um because they can augment you you may
not have had the education in school uh
to pursue the dream that you want but
you know you can use eventually an AI
co-pilot to enable you to do that
you know we're gonna move towards a
world in which uh the stuff that is dull
dangerous or dirty that people don't
want to do will be done by robots and by
AI algorithms and so forth but those who
truly you know want to be creatives want
to be entrepreneurs want to have a dream
you know what did you want to do as a
kid before the world told you you
couldn't do it
um I mean that's truly uh magical uh you
know Chris you and I are lucky uh we are
doing what we love a lot of parts of the
world they don't have that luxury you
know they're doing what's possible to
put food on their table or get insurance
for their family and and we're gonna
we're gonna be transforming that that's
part of the process of uplifting
Humanity so you're hoping that through
technology you can liberate people from
doing things that they have to do to
allowing them to do things that they
want to do yeah it's so one of the
concepts I I wrote my first book uh with
Stephen kotler in 2012 called abundant
really really cool guy yeah he's
brilliant
um uh you know the book is called
abundance the future is better than you
think and I called Stephen I had Stephen
had written about me when I was running
the xprize foundation
um and he did a wired and a GQ article
and I remember thinking this guy writes
really well I love his writing and I
called him up and I said will you give
me writing lessons so I took writing
lessons from Stephen and then I said I
really want to do a book one of these
days so I called him up I was at
Singularity Universities at our second
year and the idea of abundance that
there's nothing truly scarce in the
world
what do I mean by that you know people
talk about water wars and water scarcity
but the reality is there's water
everywhere
um there we live on a water planet right
we're a blue green Planet two-thirds of
our surface is covered by water the
challenge is to you know 97.5 percent
assault
two percent is ice and we fight over a
half a percent of the fresh water on the
planet but Waters there it's just not in
the usable form and Technology we're
getting ready to launch a uh 100 million
dollar uh energy efficient desalination
prize right we did a atmospheric uh
water extraction prize to pull water out
of the atmosphere so there are
technologies that can make water
abundant everywhere you know energy we
used to kill whales on the ocean to get
whale oil to light our Knights to read
then we ravaged mountainsides for coal
then we drilled kilometers into the
ocean for oil and natural gas
um
but the Earth is covered in 8 000 times
more energy from the Sun than we consume
as a species the energy is there just
not in the usable form and so we see
this over and over and over again and
the idea is technology takes
um takes uh what's scarce and turns it
into abundance over and over again right
abundant access information on Google
abundant communication on our cellular
networks and so I don't think there's
anything truly scarce and uh and part of
my mission is how people see that
abundance mindset
Michael malice is a cultural commentator
podcaster writer he's just released a
book called the white pill and I sat
down with him to talk about that this
week
he is Railing at the moment against a
culture of cynicism as he calls it
people that tell you that this isn't
going to get better it can't get better
things have always been this way the bad
people are always going to win now he's
done it in a slightly different way
um he describes in gruesome detail for
300 Pages all of the worst crimes of
Soviet era Russia of the Ukraine what
happened in Romania famine prisons
gulags abuse
nepotism everything
and then he rounds out the book by
saying and look what happened the bad
people didn't win in the end the Berlin
Wall fell essentially overnight
and he continues to load up many many
more examples like that
and yet
there is still a pervasive culture of
cynicism I think
there is I have some I have a I know who
does it
what do you mean who causes that
it's the news media
uh it's it's what I call the crisis News
Network
you know CNN or I don't know a good
acronym for Fox so the reality is our
brains evolved to look for bad news
right because a hundred thousand years
ago a squiggle on the ground wasn't a
stick it was a snake or a Russell in the
leaves wasn't you know the wind it was a
uh you know a a lion
um you were dead if you missed that so
we evolved an ancient piece of our
temporal lobe of our brain called the
amygdala which is the first place all of
our sensory input Eyes Ears touch and so
forth go and your amygdala puts you in
Red Alert if it senses any potential
Danger
and because of that we paid 10 times
more attention to negative use and
positive news
and because what's the news media's
business it's to deliver their
advertisers to our our eyeballs
and so we paid 10 times more attention
to negative news and positive news and
so that's what they feed us constantly
we see every murder in our living room
over and over and over and over again
every crooked politician every problem
on the planet
um and I'm not saying it isn't true I'm
saying it is disproportionately 10 to 1
negative there's so many amazing things
going on in the world that we never hear
about never see
and so I you could not pay me enough
money to watch the news
it's strange when you look at social
media and it seems like uh
a
State reinforcement a mainstream media
reinforcement
Army
uh that is packed with gullible
volunteers people who choose to
self-generate their own cynical stories
and put them out there now the first
mover may have been originally that
mainstream media was that I have an
amazing study that I think you'll love
so the uh 2013 Boston Marathon bombing
2012.
there was a study done on that compared
two cohorts of people the first cohort
were Runners who were in the actual race
and the second cohort were people who
had consumed six or more hours of news
media about the race the people that
consumed the six or more hours of news
media showed greater signs of PTSD and
emotional trauma than the ones who were
literally there and actually involved
yeah I mean so listen if you're
listening to this consider buying back
10 20 hours of your week by shutting off
the TV
don't read the newspaper set a few
Google alerts for the things that are
important to you if something's really
going on the world you need to know
about believe me your friends will tell
you take back control do not let some
editor in some Newsroom who's showing
you every murder over and over again
with this dystopian mindset ruin your
day so one of the things I teach right
and I'm really passionate about this is
your mindset is everything right so I I
teach this at abundance street right 360
I have programs going on right now uh
for free to help coach people on on
mindsets if I said to you what was the
most important thing in making Steve
Jobs and Elon Musk and you know Mahatma
Gandhi whoever your leader that you I
think is amazing what made them
successful was it the money they had the
technology had they had the network they
had or was it their mindset what was the
most important thing I think most people
would agree it's their mindset you take
away everything but you retain their
mindset they would regain some level of
their success and so if your mindset is
the most important thing you have
what mindset do you have where did you
get it from
uh what mindset do you want and how are
you going to shape it right most of us
get a mindset that we inherit from our
parents that we inherit from the people
we hang out with but we don't take the
time to shape our active mindset and I
think this is a real challenge
um you know so what I teach is I focus
in on on five mindsets uh an abundance
mindset which shifts everything if you
see abundance everywhere versus scarcity
you're much more likely to be partnering
with people and giving away and getting
return an exponential mindset
understanding how fast exponential Tech
is moving and understanding that we can
transform an entire industry uh not in
20 years or 10 years but in five years I
focus on a longevity mindset that we're
going to be able to add 10 20 30 healthy
years in our lives and during that time
scientists and doing more to extend our
life beyond that and it's worth
investing in your health today to be
able to get ready for those extensions
and then a moonshot mindset where you
really give yourself permission to go 10
times bigger where everyone else is
going 10 and finally a curiosity mindset
which feeds all of these things so I
think your mind mindset I guard my
mindset I guard it by what I watch
what I read who I hang out with
and it's I think it's one of the most
important things for uh for
entrepreneurs today when it comes to
applying this to actually doing
something in terms of practices so long
you're talking about mindset you know
just see the abundance in your life stop
watching the media these are ingrained
habits not only are these ingrained
habits they're ingrained habits that are
largely invisible to us I know if
there's a cookie there I can observe my
hand go toward it and the cookie go
toward my mouth and we eat it and then
feel ashamed about myself right whereas
when it comes to mindset it's so much
more ephemeral and wishy-washy and
invisible to us it doesn't Galvanize Us
in the same sort of a way someone
listens they say abundance mindset
sounds fantastic I want to step up I
want to make a change yeah what are the
steps that make the biggest difference
yeah so here's an interesting way to
think about it uh if unless you've been
living under a rock you've been uh
seeing the the rise of uh gpt3 and chat
GPT and all of these uh these neural net
AI systems and so it turns out that our
brain is a neural net
right and the same way that you train an
AI
uh an AI neural net you show it in very
famous examples that Google did you show
it cat video after cat video after cat
video and it begins to recognize what a
cat is and it's showing an a neural net
data sets and those data sets train the
neural net
uh in this and our brain is neural net
so if you are watching uh use uh my
favorite example again if you're
watching the crisis News Network over
and over and over again your brain is
going to be wired uh in a sense of PTSD
it's going to be wired of all of this to
expect negativism you're going to see
something and it'll scare you even
though it may not be scary right you
hear the rustle in the leaves and it's
it should it's the wind but you think
it's someone you know with a sniper
rifle
um and so uh it's training your neural
net by what you read what you watch and
who you hang out with right it's all the
data you're letting in it's how do you
train yourself
and depending on how your neural net is
trained again
the podcast you listen to like where we
are here
um uh and and it's when you have
an opportunity a conversation you can
color it negative or positive
and that is a default mechanism based
upon uh your your mindsets
so I I actually have a 30-day mindset
boot camp that's free
um you can Google Third Day mindset Boot
Camp or go to diamandis.com uh you can
you can find it there and it's step by
step by step it's my job when I'm
teaching this is to give you
undeniable overwhelming evidence of the
extraordinary world and how it's getting
better and better and better on every
single level
to counter the dystopian news and then
to recommend to you
um you know
read you know books listen to podcasts
taking information
that is going to shape your your mind so
when I was starting the International
Space University I'll never forget my
co-founder Todd Hawley were in the same
same room at a desk opposite each other
and as a joke he put up Murphy's Law
behind him
and so facing my desk and Murphy's Law
is if anything can go wrong it will and
I'm like I hate that I kept on just like
just take it down take it and he
wouldn't just to bug me and so I I had a
white board I put on it if anything can
go wrong fix it to hell with Murphy
right and that's a flip of that mindset
and then I ended up creating
32 different Peter's laws in that you
know and given a choice take both start
at the top and work your way up but
it's about it's about Shifting the way
you think it's a judo move so to speak
Reagan when he came into power and he
was told that the Soviet era is going to
continue this is the way that the world
is now you're going to have this
permanent sort of armament War ever
escalating nuclear threat uh this is the
way it is we need to you need to learn
to work around this and he said
um I have another idea
some may call my plan simple or even
simplistic
we win they lose
that was his plan uh and that's the same
as writing on the boards
yeah good good on him so what you've
what you've mentioned here is that you
can provide people with relatively
undeniable proof about uh the reduction
in climate Associated deaths the
increase in child mortality the increase
in the decrease in traffic yeah sorry uh
um
etc etc
yes somebody that has imbibed a
sufficiently cynical mindset will be
able to say well yeah that's for them
that's for out there that's for
everybody else me life doesn't seem to
work out that way I have a x y z reason
why that is not the case
what about someone who has fortified
themselves inside of a uh a helpless
victim mindset or or scarcity inside
themselves
I I think ultimately anybody can can
Will themselves to death and can Will
themselves into that mindset if they if
they so choose
um
I think you have to get up and go to
where it's better meaning hang out with
people who see the world differently
than you
um you know the old adage you're the
average of The Five People You spend the
most time with if you're overweight
hang out with skinny people if you're
out of shape hang out with people who
are in [__] in good shape right if you
think the world is going to hell in a
handbasket
if you can find people who think the
world is amazing and that it's the most
extraordinary time ever to be alive
and get into those conversations now you
have to be motivated to do that and
something is to kick you in the pants
um and maybe you'll be hitting rock
bottom maybe you'll be your husband wife
boyfriend girlfriend your parents
whatever the case might be but it it is
possible
um
and I mean I I wrote abundance for that
purpose and uh you know it's the story
behind abundance where we look at
uh going from scarcity to abundance in
every area Food Water Energy Healthcare
education learning How uh
is got the the story has gotten
incredibly stronger in the last 11 years
on every level
um you know the only place that's been a
challenge has been in the environment
and even then uh there is a
extraordinary uh tsunami of Technologies
coming to support uh that uh that change
in that repair
when it comes to your current pet
Obsession of longevity and health yes
I think we both agree that human life
has kind of already been a little
overclocked that we are living to ages
now that are pretty much unprecedented
our bodies largely don't know what to do
when they get to these sorts of Ages we
we weren't designed to live to 80 90 you
know having centered generians having
people that live over 100 is insane it's
absolutely insane so
given that
what what hope have we got that we can
continue to extend something which has
already been overclocked
so great question I'll give you a couple
of thoughts there and and you're right
our our bodies were never really
designed to live past age 30. now I'll
use that number you know 100 000 years
ago early hominids would be getting
puberty at age 12 13.
and by time you were 13 or 14 you were
pregnant
by the time you were
26 27 28 you were a grandparent and
before food was
abundant everywhere before McDonald's
and Whole Foods existed uh the last
thing you wanted to do if you wanted to
perpetuate the species was to take food
out of the mouths of your grandchildren
and so you you die and there was never
any selective pressure
after reproduction to keep us alive
longer so very true our average human
lifespan was late 20s and then 100 years
ago was late 30s into 40 and then has
grown now to Quality 100 years ago it
was 13 to 40s it was it was late 30s
into early 40s yes have you got any idea
what happens if you take deaths under
five out of that equation it goes up yep
um there's uh there's no question it was
the average lifespan but what increased
it substantially was uh better
sanitation antibiotics better calories
and all of that
um so that's the first point in terms of
uh the second point is
there are species on this planet of uh
bowhead whales that live 200 years uh
Greenland sharks that live for 500 years
and I remember when I was in medical
school I asked the question if they
could live that long why can't we
and I said it's either a hardware
problem or a software problem
and I am clear that it's this decade
that we're going to understand the root
cause of that
so just because we were never engineered
to live past our reproductive age
does not mean that the systems could not
be engineered to do that and so the work
that I'm doing right now uh that I'm
funding through my fund that we are
working on through xprize and through
some of my companies
and supporting some of the top thinkers
like George church and David Sinclair is
really around the notion of how do we
get consistently to 100 to 120 and then
can we in fact actually get uh you know
further can we get to 150 years old
um and so uh I don't think uh the answer
is
um
uh impossible I think we're going to get
there I think AI is going to enable us
to understand
the you know 3.2 billion letters and
what is going on there I think Quantum
technologies that are coming online and
in this decade is going to be the big
push it's going to help us understand
what's going on the model the human uh
uh life form in great detail
um the other thing to note that's super
interesting is you know we have 3.2
billion letters for my mother and from
our father
and that genome is set when you're born
and it's the same exact genome when
you're 20 when you're 40 when you're 80
when you're 100 so if you've got the
same instructions that why do you look
different
well it's not your genome it's what
genes are on and what genes are off it's
your epigenome it's the control of that
Symphony of genes
and as we grow older we accumulate some
amount of DNA damage true but what goes
awry is the is the silencing of genes
and the wrong genes are on the wrong
genes are off and so the work that's
exciting right now is in epigenetic
reprogramming can we set back the clock
and so in animal models and in human uh
cellular models we've been able to do
that
so uh I for one am doing everything I
can to remain in the best possible shape
uh and uh and backing the research uh to
move that forward
because I think we can add healthy
decades onto our life
and those healthy decades will buy us
additional Decades of breakthrough in
science and technology to add more
decades into our life that concept is
called Longevity escape velocity and
we'll we'll see
I think up until this decade for every
generation that you were born you gained
about an extra eight years on average I
think yeah the number has been a quarter
of a year per year
um you know we've seen some setbacks in
the coveted years these last two years
um and I'll be interesting to see post
covid do we retain do we return to that
situation let's say that we didn't
inject any new Gene editing crispr you
know
um how would you say like power law
advances
um what do you think is the I'm using
the words very Loosely natural limit
yeah so listen we have we we know from
history that the
very rare
oldest lived individuals are 120 121 122
123 I think is the longest accurately uh
documented living individual then we
have super centenarians
who are uh you know get to 105 years old
now the difference between normal
individuals and super centenarians
um is the difference between Health span
and lifespan
so you can be alive at 100 brainless in
a wheelchair drooling or you can be
alive at 100 playing golf having going
to work every day having being a sharp
contributing individual
and and that's being that's Health span
versus lifespan and in super
centenarians
um you know in in normal individuals
will have a health span till 65 and then
a slow
or slow decrease from 65 to 80 and then
die
super centenarian you know so you have
15 years of ailments aches pains in and
out of the hospital not feeling well not
enjoying life forced into retirement
super centenarians may have 95 years of
great health and then
they fall off a cliff of two years of
illness and then die right so the goal
is extend health span as long as
possible
um
and
you know that's great and I think that
is possible with exercise with sleep
with diet uh with mindset with not dying
from something stupid so I'll give you a
few examples there because I think
they're important
um on diet I'm in the middle right now
every year with my abundance 360 group I
do a 22 day no sugar challenge
um and so we're on a WhatsApp group is
150 of us right now on this and we share
what we're eating and doing and for 22
days you it's no carbs no sugar no high
glycemic and it's night and day going
through a group along with that but it
turns out in diet if there's one thing
you want to do it's eliminate high
glycemic index foods and in particular
sugar sugar is a poison for the body
um it's a neurotoxin it's a
cardiovascular toxin
um and it's just
we never evolved right sugar cane was
not part of our diet uh a thousand or a
hundred thousand years ago
uh and so it's an inflammatory
so that's diet in its simplest you know
I have a Mediterranean diet I uh I do
get enough protein to try and keep up
muscle second thing exercise I think
muscle mass is one of the most important
elements in the body it has the highest
correlation to longevity
so I will try and get my 7 000 minimum
10 000 Target steps in a day and then
try and get into three workouts a week
um sleep uh I'm clear eight hours of
sleep is my target every day I used to
like be proud of getting five hours when
I was in medical school and now I'm
proud of like when I hit eight hours on
my aura ring that's eight hours tracked
so probably closer to eight and a half
nine hours in bed is that right it is
I'm typically in bed at 9 30 uh and up
at 5 30 6 the latest
I know so what your sleep efficiency
must be very high if that's okay it it
is it is I do get uh I I'm I fall asleep
very easily I'm lacking in that regard
um so but uh you know there's a whole
bunch of hacks on sleep I use an eye
mask that I love a manta eye mask I have
a cooling blanket I set the temperature
outside at 65 degrees I don't eat within
the last couple hours of uh of going to
sleep and it's all basic stuff
um
uh there's a great book called why uh
why we sleep
um which is amazing uh and then
um not dying from something stupid is
very important and it's I jokingly about
it but very few of us know what's
actually going on inside our body like
if I said to you do you know that
there's nothing going on inside your
body that that you need to know that you
don't know about that you're concerned
about does that feel fine
but here's the fact the body is
incredibly good at hiding problems
like you don't go to the doctor with
pains and aches and so forth until it's
a stage three or stage four cancer
um
if you have Parkinson's the Tremors
don't show up until 70 of the neurons
are gone
and so I built a company called Fountain
life it's operational in four centers
right now and we're growing to 20
centers around the world
and we do uh in fact I'm going tonight
or tomorrow I'm going to Naples Florida
where our lead Center is for my annual
upload and so I'll go there it's about
five hours it's a full body MRI head to
head to toe a brain Imaging brain blood
flow I do a coronary CT using an AI
overlay looking for soft plaque not
calcified plaque soft plaque is what can
kill you a dexa scan genomics uh a Grail
cancer test anyway it's 150 gigabytes of
data
and I after that scan I'm clear
about what's going on in every nook and
cranny my body
and I've been doing this now for eight
years and I have a Baseline and I'm
looking for any variation and someday
something's going to happen it's going
to show up but I will have caught it at
stage zero or stage one when it's the
best chance of doing something about it
how frequently are you doing this once a
year and then uh the the fountain Life
program is just fountainlife.com is a
once a year upload then a quarterly uh
follow-up uh blood test and it's really
uh it's the fiduciary for your health
and then part of Fountain life is is is
the most advanced Diagnostics and their
half is the most advanced therapeutic so
we are looking around the world for any
breakthroughs uh any new science any new
technologies that extend the health span
of the individual we make that available
to Fountain life centers so I like to
say listen
um you know more about what you're
what's going on inside your car than you
do your body
and so if you can afford it
um it's not cheap it's 20K a year but
you get a concierge doctor along with it
uh one thing we did do last year to make
it more available is we launched
Fountain health insurance
and Fountain health is uh companies of
50 employees or more
for the same price you're paying for
your current health insurance for your
employees
found Health gives all the testing
for free our mission is to find the
disease in the beginning where it's
cheap to handle versus at the end where
it's expensive I've heard you say it's
not Healthcare it's sickness care it is
it's ridiculous right so like I I hate
the fact that health insurance pays you
after you're sick life insurance pays
your next chicken after you're dead
right fire insurance pays you after your
house burned down it's perverse yeah
speaking of some how would you say
progressive treatments I'm going to
Colombia in a month's time to get some
stem cell treatments over there what
have been your experiences so far I
haven't done the country of Colombia yes
correct okay University of Columbia
University uh yeah I'm going down to
Medellin
um what should what should I expect what
have your experience being with it
so let's talk about stem cells a second
um and unfortunately stem cell treatment
exogenous stem cells stem cells from a
newborn uh placental or Cord Blood stem
cells are not legally administerable in
the United States they have not been
approved by the FDA so I'm going to
Medellin yeah right and so we send
people to typically a facility in Costa
Rica they're in Colombia they're in
Mexico they're in Panama
um and and so
um
listen uh our bodies uh when we're born
have stem cells in every tissue and
those stem cells are the regenerative
reparative engines of those tissues
right so stem cells uh in your skin are
replenishing skin stem cells in your
muscle in your brain in your kidney and
your liver in your fat is replenishing
those those organs and tissues
and the problem is again because we were
never evolved to live past age 30
as we grow older the stem cell
populations Reduce by a hundred fold or
a thousand fold
and uh the question is can you
supplement them can you rejuvenate and
regenerate the stem cell populations
and so
um I have believe it or not my first
stem cell treatment coming up this
spring I've been doing exosomes
which are the information packets that
that stem cells put out
um but the other thing I'm doing is I'm
extracting my own stem cells fat stem
cells and uh and bone marrow stem cells
and storing them
uh for future uh future infusion so uh I
have
thousands of friends who have gone
through this and
um
I think uh people have everything from I
didn't notice anything to it was amazing
I'm I'm renewed and rejuvenated
so uh it's something which is not
consistent for everybody
um I think stem cells typically traffic
to areas where there's damage and you
need uh need repair whether it's joints
um or uh muscles I think uh we're going
to discover a lot about stem cells but
they're one of you know the 100 to a
thousand X reduction in stem cells is
one of the Hallmarks of aging and I
think it is possible to rejuvenate that
when it comes to your Suite of tools
that you're using in order to extend
longevity yeah diet sleep exercise don't
do anything stupid mindset yeah why are
you not bringing up sunlight or heat or
cold exposure why does that not factor
in it for you it does so I do uh I do a
cold shower every morning I do a hot
shower first and then I'll turn it on
the freezing and I'll glass as long as I
can I just don't have a cold plunge set
up but I love love it and saunas are
great they're an important part I just
need to pull it in to my current living
environment which I have not done yet
but where I can do it I definitively do
that uh there's a whole bunch of
different supplements uh and meds that I
do take I don't want to be you know
practice medicine I can say what I do uh
right
um I take about a gram of Metformin
every day right which reduces blood
glucose levels
um I supplement my testosterone to bring
it up to uh you know optimal levels
um I'm taking six gram milligrams of
rapamycin uh right now and then a whole
slew of supplements and again
um
I think on my diamandis.com there's all
of my longevity protocols everything I'm
doing uh accessible there
when it comes to your use of uh
supplementation in terms of trt
I have read and heard a number of
concerns around higher testosterone
levels being associated with lower
longevity is that a concern for you that
the therapeutic levels of trt are
potentially uh lowering lifespan I I
haven't I have not seen that uh that
science
um and I'm not I'm basically
supplementing to get to normal rates I'm
not looking to get to supernormal rates
you know
um and there's you know it's interesting
the level of complexity
of the human body and our biochemistry
and our cellular chemistry is
extraordinary
uh and one of the things that is coming
is finally the amount of uh
data science that can look at everything
look at all so you know we have this 150
gigabytes of data that we get about of
all of our members that go through
abundance 360 we know what they're
taking we know what their complaints are
we know what everything and what will
fall out of all that data is
correlations like for this genetic
situation for these supplements and it's
it's still the early days but the decade
ahead is going to be amazing
that's the longevity escape velocity
that you're talking about stick about
keep your health as good as it can be
because at some point in the future
we're going to be able to add more than
a year for every year that you stay
alive
um one of the things I was interested
looking at your approach to diet which
is quite plant heavy which is quite
Mediterranean how do you square the
circle of the Paleo and carnivore
Community being so popular and having so
many people that extol it as a virtue
with your view of Leaning heavily on
plants and have actually a quite heavy
reduction in red meat so listen I eat as
much fish as I can I I eat as many eggs
as I can so I do believe in a high
protein intake
but also a high plant intake I stay away
from red meats doesn't mean I don't
enjoy some bacon once in a while or uh
some pork once in a while
you know there's an old Greek saying my
dad used to say upon Metro notation
which is everything in moderation
so I lean heavily
like I attack vegetables right and put
on olive oil and everything that I could
possibly put olive oil on like a good
Greek man yeah good Greek yes and uh and
I will if I have any choice uh I'll be
eating salmon
um uh wherever I can and and uh you know
three or four eggs in a day
so
you know and then the reality is all
diets are not made for everybody
uh your your ethnic background
does affect what diet's right for you
and I think the other thing that we're
discovering right now is your microbiome
is plays such a huge role
and everything again it's every time we
learn about something in the microbiome
like oh my God where'd that come from
that's crazy uh and it's
it's we're collecting data uh I'm doing
what in summary I think gives me the
best shot at I I feel like I'm in better
shape and have more energy and more you
know desire to you know to go out there
and make my Dent Universe than I ever
had
uh and that's great and my goal is you
know I'm 61 can I keep it going for the
next 30 Years intercept of 30 years of
of Technology change and I'll be blown
away if that if we're not adding another
30 years during that time
I know that you're a user of athletic
greens I have been for a very long time
as well is that you're going to lean
over and pull out there it is there it
is travel packs so
um
one of the things that I had read again
this is coming out of the Paleo Carnival
Community is a concern of over
consumption of leafy greens which is
what I my favorite vegetable if I could
dial it in all the time would be spinach
yeah um it's just great
um but oxalates is that what I mean yeah
yes and athletic greens and stuff which
is uh hyper condensed uh very
um potent delivery of this sort of stuff
how concerned should I be about oxalates
can I tell all of my friends that have
prodded me about it that they need to go
away
if I had any true knowledge I would give
it to you but I don't so best to not say
anything
um I'll look into it but um I I love the
product and it it sort of gets me
through uh my early morning fasting the
bottom line is and I think that you use
this as a good heuristic how do you feel
yeah you feel better uh and I've just
had this morning my first full blood
panel done by marrick health which meant
that I had to stay off anything that's
got biotin because that can sometimes
skew the results I didn't even know what
biotin was but I haven't used athletic
greens for probably in fact I didn't use
it because I was at home and I ran out
in the UK I wasn't abused it for two
weeks I don't feel as good my digestion
doesn't feel as good I can tell that
there's something just not quite right
uh and then I had to do the thing today
and as soon as I've got it out of the
way I'm like I'm I'm back on that and
it's the same as do you eat some awful
fast food
Motorway Services how do you feel after
you've eaten it your body knows you know
yeah and you regret you ate it yeah one
of the things that's going on it's one
of the benefits of uh of intermittent
fasting uh and having something light
and energy dense and vibrant is if it
doesn't pull all of the blood out of
your brain into your digestive tract you
know so you feel slow and sluggish one
of the benefits I remember the first
time I ever started doing intermittent
fasting and wouldn't eat until like one
o'clock I was like bouncing off the off
the walls with energy I was like that's
crazy why do I have so much energy it's
because my my uh blood is not drawn to
my digestive tract if you have a heavy
breakfast
and also your system is thinking you
need to be fo you need to be focused
here we might we might need to look
around for an antelope or we need to be
we need to be on the lookout for a good
Bush absolutely yeah
um
it is very interesting man I I've very
much been enjoying taking a more I'm
such a bro right so my Inception into
the health and fitness world was playing
a sport as a kid at a pretty high level
until about the age of 18 and then as
soon as I got to University all that I
wanted to do was look jacked so for and
this was the Advent the absolute cusp of
the If It Fits your Macros movement
which is you can get shredded eating
Haribo and cheesecake as long as it hits
the macronutrient profile that you need
to micros that's kind of lame no one
cares that's for [__] uh you don't
need to care about sunlight you don't
need to care about it was just the most
transactional approach to health right
optimized you know my aesthetic physique
was and that says a lot that you can
look absolutely fantastic on the outside
also I mean I was 20 whatever in my 20s
which means you can probably do pretty
much anything in your silicon yes
but now you know I'm 34 and I'm
genuinely taking more care about this
I'm thinking like how many steps am I
getting in per day am I going for a
little walk to reduce insulin
sensitivity after each meal how much
sunlight am I getting exposed to how
much time am I spending in nature am I
getting enough heat am I getting enough
cold what's my water content like not
only is how much am I drinking but what
is the quality of the water that I'm
getting like we've got a reverse osmosis
uh filter that's just arrived in the
living room which I'm excited to start
using bing bing bing like all the way
down is that reverse osmosis water as
well
it is what do you use do you use an aqua
true or something else it's a it's a
system we point to the house so oh
you've plugged it right in wow okay yeah
that would be absolutely fantastic my
point being
I have I think mostly my age the age
that I was at moved along with most of
the developments it feels to me like
people have started talking about the
things that I've started doing at the
time when I needed to start doing them
now that might just be as a byproduct
that you start searching for those sorts
of things but certainly this push
towards sunlight heat cold uh a more
holistic view of Health you know that is
you need to look good but you need to
actually operate well too if you're
crumbling on the inside but shining on
the outside it's not very useful yeah
for sure
and and remember this is the most
extraordinary time ever to be alive uh
only time more exciting than now is
tomorrow and it's like you want to be
look good you know think clearly move
well be able to enjoy the life ahead and
when my friend says you want a future
that's bigger than your past and if
you've got that then you're going to
live into that extraordinary future
if there was a bunch of headlines of
things that you wish you could tell
people to stop taking or stop doing in
service of their longevity what are the
biggest wastes that don't move the
needle that you wish people wouldn't
focus on
uh I started with one don't waste your
time watching the news uh become uh
become selective on what you let into
your mind uh this is an extraordinary
time
um so guard your what shapes your neural
net uh the best on the food side it's
get rid of sodas uh fruit juices are you
know insane uh but it's sugary
substances and carbs can you can you
reduce your your glucose intake that's
an issue with diet drinks
uh
you know the phosphoric acid in in uh in
diet drinks so I just don't do sodas
listen I I may do a Coke Zero once a
year but it's not like you know
um and then I
you know it's
it really is about
um
it's it's not any one thing
um but it's make a few small don't try
and do everything make a few small
changes in your life
uh in these areas I think sleep is one
of the biggest changes people can make
that changes everything because it fuels
you
um so uh it's nothing there's no other
stop doing uh that I would I would list
ladies and gentlemen if people want to
keep up to date with the stuff that you
do where should they go yeah sure so my
podcast is uh called moonshots and
mindsets and uh uh it's really a deep
focus on all of these areas uh uh I'm on
Twitter and Instagram at Peter diamandis
and then
uh diamantis.com is all of my blogs and
all of the tools and all the products
that I I provide folks so listen I'm on
a mission to inspiring guide
entrepreneurs to create a hopeful
abundant uh and compelling future and
that's what I love doing and Chris thank
you very much for having me on the show
today thank you
close then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]